[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue pour une émission qui sera
entièrement consacrée à l'ondé de choc
et surtout aux mesures à prendre après
l'horrible assassinat de samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire tué et décapité
vendredi dernier par ce qu'il avait
montré des caricatures de charlie hebdo
à ses élèves de collège pour parler de
ce sujet grave deux invités bonsoir
laurent alexandre soit vous êtes médecin
essayiste entrepreneur vous avez créé il
ya très longtemps le site doctissimo
vous êtes aujourd'hui à la tête entre
autres de la start-up dna vision qui est
spécialisé dans le séquençage de l'adn
votre dernier livre jouissez jeunesse a
été publié chez lattès nous avons aussi
le plaisir d'accueillir ivan rioufol
bonsoir yves encore vous êtes
journaliste bien sûr éditorialiste au
figaro essayiste on retrouve chaque
vendredi
votre bloc-notes dans les colonnes du
figaro est votre dernier livre le réveil
des somnambules est d'ailleurs un
recueil de vos dernières chroniques ça a
été publié aux éditions de l'artilleur
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin a révélé il ya quelques heures
son ambition sa volonté de dissoudre des
associations dont les principes sont
contraires aux valeurs de la république
et en particulier le tristement célèbre
cci eef collectif contre l'islamophobie
en france
déjà des voix s'élèvent pour s'opposer à
ce que certains considèrent comme une
limite à la liberté d'expression
autre projet qui est dans l'air mieux
encadrer les réseaux sociaux le
gouvernement recevait aujourd'hui les
patrons français des principaux réseaux
cette idée elle est dans l'air comme
celle de la levée de l'anonymat
écoutez ce qu'en pense xavier bertrand
c'est le président de la région des
hautes france il était hier l'invité du
grand jury rtl le figaro lci
il faut que l'anonymat pour ceux qui
font l'apologie du terrorisme sur ces
réseaux sociaux soit levé beaucoup plus
vite et vous avez une façon très simple
de le faire vous ouvrez un compte vous
devez donner votre identité
juste à l'hébergeur comme ça s'il ya des
menaces s'il y a une apologie du
terrorisme
on va pas mettre autant de temps que
cela
à fermer et surtout à pouvoir condamner
et poursuit c'est un lieu d'impunité
et puis pour lancer le débat y avoir une
autre voie
je vous propose de regarder ce tweet
d'un habitué de point de vue puisqu'il
s'agit de l'essayiste libéral fergane à
ziari faire gagner il est tout à fait
opposés à l'idée de confier à des
fonctionnaires le soin de sélectionner
les bonnes et les mauvaises idéologie la
lutte et culturelles non juridique dit
il plongé les idéologies ennemis dans la
clandestinité ne nous aidera pas ivan
rioufol est ce que vous êtes partisan de
d'un encadrement juridique plus strict
de ce qu'ils peuvent être les voix de
l'islamisme même si c'est au détriment
de la liberté d'expression foncièrement
contre foncièrement contre et ce serait
contre-productif d'ailleurs ce serait
irresponsable politiquement car en fait
on nous demande la de nous mobiliser
contre une censure islamistes dans le
fond et se mobiliser contre une censure
islamistes à travers le délit de
blasphème par exemple qui voudraient
interdire la critique de l'islam on ne
va pas y répondre par une censure au
républicaine si je puis dire qui serait
celle de mettre sous surveillance des
réseaux sociaux là où précisément toutes
là contre le contre discours se
construit alors naturellement il ya des
excès dans les réseaux sociaux où j'en
suis bien d'accord
oui les réseaux sociaux sont un
thermomètre c'est le révélateur de ce
qu'est également 2,7 contre société
islamiste là donc ça ne servirait à rien
de cassé les réseaux sociaux si l'on
veut ne pas entendre c'est cette cette
force jihadistes dans le fond qui
s'exprime également à travers ces
réseaux là donc ce serait
contre-productif et ce serait de mon
point de vue il responsable et pourtant
si par exemple il n'y avait pas eu sur
les réseaux ces appels à la mobilisation
contre ce malheureux professeur
d'histoire peut-être serait-il toujours
en vie aujourd'hui
écoutez qu'il y ait des surveillance des
réseaux sociaux qu'il y ait une
application de ce qu'est le droit en
disant que le droit naturellement
réprime les appels à la haine les appels
à la violence les appels au meurtre
ceux ci j'en suis bien d'accord et
lorsqu'elle a il y avait des ddd
et surtout des procédures à mettre en
oeuvre qui sont peut-être des procédures
qui sont améliorées je suis bien
d'accord avec ceux ci
mais encore une fois il ne faudrait pas
accuser les réseaux sociaux des mots de
la de l'islamisation de la société la
société française n'a pas attendu les
réseaux sociaux pour 6 la visée dans
l'indifférence générale donc s'il y a
des coupables
ce ne sont pas les réseaux sociaux s'il
ya des coupables il faut aller
rechercher chez les islamistes mais il
faut lire chercher également chez ceux
qui ont permis à ces islamistes la de
s'exprimer en creusant le grand vide
français dans le fond dans lequel
l'islam s'est introduit alors alexandre
vous êtes très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux vous avez 73 mille abonnés sur
twitter ils vont presque autant
d'ailleurs 70 milles 6 g si j'ai bien lu
vous êtes très actif est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut réguler les réseaux
sociaux pour faire baisser le niveau de
haine dans notre pays
je suis d'accord avec yvan c'est pas en
faisant la même chose que les islamistes
et en supprimant la liberté d'expression
qu'on va résoudre le problème [ __ ]
dehors les imams radicaliser est ce
qu'on a jamais fait après charlie ce
qu'on n'a pas fait après nice et qu'on
doit faire aujourd'hui oui mais bloquer
la liberté d'expression de tous les
citoyens pour en pensant répondre à
cette crise d'islamisme radical serait
contre-productif par ailleurs les appels
à la haine qu'il ya eu sur les réseaux
sociaux n'était pas du tout anonyme et
la vidéo qui était sur youtube du père
de famille qui faisait croire que sa
fille avait été choqué alors qu'elle
n'était même pas elle n'avait pas ce
professeur en cours n'était pas du tout
anonyme
donc en réalité les gens qui ont attisé
la haine n'était pas anonyme dans ce cas
là nous ne sommes pas face à un problème
de l'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux on
est face à un problème culturel
il ya un défi civilisationnel qui se
posent en france avec une
communautarisation larvée et qui est
agressive marginalement certes mais
agressive de plus en plus donc les
réseaux sociaux sont un un bouc
émissaire facile mais ce n'est pas le
problème
le problème c'est la lâcheté de l'état
c'est la montée d'un islam au gauchisme
depuis des années et des années que
manuel valls et bernard cazeneuve ont
ces dernières heures
pointée du doigt c'est ça la réalité il
est très frappante
voir que un homme aussi raisonnable que
bernard cazeneuve dont on ne peut pas
dire l'ancien premier ministre que ce
soit un excité est pointé la
responsabilité des islamo gauchiste de
la france y est soumise comme il l'a
fait ces dernières heures un de façon à
peine plus diplomatique que manuel valls
quand il a accusé jean luc mélenchon
d'avoir une part de responsabilité dans
la décapitation du fait qu'il a
accueilli beaucoup d'islamo gauchistes
chez les insoumis et est-ce que vous
tiendriez le même raisonnement ivan
rioufol donc de deux de laisser faire
entre guillemets pour les associations
comme le comme le ccf qui pourtant ne
vous a pas ménagés cours de ces
dernières années et même fait un procès
que j'ai gagné en appel
c'est pour une organisation il a perdu
également oui il fait lille mène à jihad
judiciaire mais de la même manière je
serai également réservé alors
naturellement il ne faut rien lâcher au
ccm non content qu'on a appris ce matin
ça j'ai appris ce matin par la bouche du
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il
bénéficiait de subventions publiques et
de défiscalisation dans le fond ceci est
tout à fait naturellement odieux en même
temps je mets en garde également sur
cette volonté de censure qui voudraient
tout prix clouer le bec des opposants
parce que le ccf naturellement est
épouvantable dans sa danse aux
idéologies qui est de vouloir me voir de
l'islamophobie partout c'est à dire de
vouloir afficher chez quiconque élise
est désigné comme étant d'islamophobe
une sorte de deux tirs à vue dans le
fond en tout cas de permis de tuer pour
ceux qui comprennent que l'islamophobie
doit être sanctionné donc naturellement
c'est un mouvement qui doit être ciblée
c'est un mouvement qui doit être
décortiquées dans ces financements je
voudrais savoir si ce que je lis de de
la ferment de soros notamment à travers
cette organisation est vrai ou pas je
n'en sais rien mais enfin il paraîtrait
qu'il bénéficierait de financement
également de ce multi milliardaire qui
prône la société ouverte donc je
voudrais que je veux
je voudrais que l'on s'éveille en tout
cas je ne suis que je suis contre les
censures je suis fondamentalement toutes
les libertés d'expression
même les libertés d'expression les plus
odieuses donc ce n'est pas moi qui
viendraient plaidé pour l'interdiction
pure et simple du ccrp je plaide en
effet pour sa mise en accusation pour la
l'idéologie qui le corps porte qu'il
faut qu'ils colportent et pour savoir
qui sont derrière ceux qui ont intérêt
effectivement à ce que ce mouvement sème
la zizanie pour être poli au coeur d'une
société fragile vous parliez de de
george soros
effectivement on a évoqué une subvention
de plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros d'open society lohan g de jambon
les comptes du ccf et essayons de
désigner quel effectivement séance sans
véritable dessin à travers des mots
d'ordre qui sont naturellement très
sympathique puisqu'il se il se promeut
comme étant le défenseur des droits de
l'homme de l'antiracisme est devenue
société caritative écouté puisque cette
émission s'appelle point de vue et même
si on travaille dans le même journal
perd maintenant un goutte à goutte est
un homme courageux parce que compte tenu
de ce que ces gens vous font subir dire
ainsi que vous ne voulez pas les réduire
au silence
il me semble est une preuve
supplémentaire que voilà vous êtes un
homme de bien je vous le dis c'est ma
conviction faites vous appel au
gouvernement pour lutter contre
l'islamisme
90% des internautes nous répondent non
christophe tout dit il faut déjà
appliquer la loi et expulser tous ceux
qui doivent l'être
nicole on aurait bien aimé que 15,9 se
manifeste quand il était au gouvernement
et puis elle ajoute il faut aussi
évident couper les vivres de toutes ces
associations en annulant toutes les
subventions bien on on y revient
laurent alexandre vous êtes d'accord
avec ivan rioufol même ces associations
qui se servent de l'islamophobie pour
contesté toute critique de l'islam il
faut pas les faire taire moi je suis
d'accord je ne suis pas partisan de la
censure et de l'interdiction de
l'expression d'un courant auquel je
n'adhère pas mais vous voyez bien le
danger
l'état n'a pas être connu depuis 20 ans
et a laissé se développer
ce courant là on a laissé une partie de
la gauche
tenir un discours islamo-gauchiste
absolument indécent et il ne faudrait
pas qu'on s'excuse de ces vingt années
de l'acheter en supprimant une
association qui est le ccf
le vrai problème est un problème
politique vous n'allez pas interdire la
france un sou mais sous prétexte qu'elle
est dans le vrai combat c'est un combat
politique qu'il faut mettre 6 jean luc
mélenchon en face de ses responsabilités
sur l'islam au gauchisme qu'ils gèrent
et qu'il qu'il a adoptée puisque les
insoumis sont devenus profondément
islamo gauchiste alors qu'on avait une
gauche laïque universaliste qui ne
voulait pas qu'ils ne voulaient pas de
discrimination qui voulait maintenir les
valeurs de la république l'égalité
hommes femmes
les insoumis sont alors même que jean
luc mélenchon est un est un laïc a
réadapté sont devenu le réceptacle de
l'islamo gauchisme insupportable et donc
oui aujourd'hui le vrai problème c'est
pas de défaire le ccf
c'est de mettre tous les hommes
politiques tous les politiciens face à
leurs responsabilités et notamment
mélenchon je suis d'accord avec manuel
valls et et cazenove qui porte une
responsabilité importante dans ce qui
s'est passé parce que ça a développé une
culture vite victimaire ça a fait croire
aux gens dans les quartiers qu'ils
étaient malheureux d'être français et
qu'ils avaient raison de ce2 de refuser
l'intégration l'assimilation et les
valeurs et les valeurs de la france
oui les insoumis ont une responsabilité
aujourd'hui il faut politiquement m jean
luc mélenchon face à ses responsabilités
politiques sur cette affaire vous êtes
d'accord une fois le combat et des
politiques plus que juridique le combat
est idéologique je suis d'accord pour
dire que mélenchon naturellement doit
être mis devant ses responsabilités car
ces compromissions sont odieuses
d'autant plus odieuse qui est son
mouvement et de parme et d'autres encore
ont appelé hier à manifester c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles je ne me
suis pas rendu personnellement à
manifester pour en mémoire
de ce professeur alors même que son
mouvement avait appelé le 10 novembre
dernier à manifester au nom d'une
islamophobie à mon prêt d'islamistes qui
ont crié à la barre dans le périmètre du
bataclan non mais je n'oublie pas ceux
ci mais en même temps je ne faudrait pas
se contenter de viser l'islamo gauchisme
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec votre
raisonnement mais il y avait quand même
également tout un abandon plus général
de la politique depuis maintenant trente
ans cela fait au moins je suis un vieux
journée cela fait plus de plus de 20 ans
que je merde mais en alerte contre
précisément cette montée d'un islam
totalitaire d'un islam qui censure et
d'un islam qui terrorise or je peux vous
assurer que pendant plus de vingt ans il
a été difficile pour moi et pour ceux
qui partageaient selon mon point de vue
de se faire entendre auprès des hommes
politiques auprès des médias même n'ont
pas dû finir on qui m'a toujours accordé
naturellement sa bienveillance et met
donc c'est tout un ensemble d'un système
politique qui s'est aveugle et
volontairement dans le fond au-delà même
de l'extrême gauche qui s'est aveugle et
en se battant la coulpe et en pensant
qu'il avait effectivement à faire
repentance à s'excuser d'être ce qu'il
est et dans le fond à s'effacer devant
une minorité qui est une minorité qui
est devenu de plus en plus tyranniques
ou non donc de de son passé colonial au
nom du métissage au nom du vivre
ensemble
au nom du respect de l'autre etc nous
nous sommes mis à genoux et nous sommes
naturellement nous avons fait deux
géants d
dhennin parce que nous parce que nous
rampons devant donc il faut absolument
inverser cette cette ligne là c'est ce
travail idéologique afin de faire en
sorte que nous ayons à nouveau confiance
en nous et vous pensez que j'entendais
encore possible est ce que vous partagez
le pessimisme de nos internautes on va
retrouver ça n'est pas un sondage mais
c'est une un questionnaire qu'on leur a
soumises sur twitter 90% des gens ne
font pas confiance au gouvernement vous
pensez vous qu'il peut y avoir une prise
de conscience après côté nous vivons un
moment dramatique que j'ai écrit j'ai
fait un blog ce matin dans lequel
j'écris qu'il faut se réveiller ou sinon
nous mourrons
je le pense très sincèrement c'est à
dire que là nous allons au bout de notre
déchéance si vraiment le gouvernement
n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'il doit
faire aujourd'hui on en appliquant la
force et non plus simplement en allumant
des petites bougies et en dessinant des
coeurs par terre s'ils n'appliquent pas
une force juridique naturellement et
peut-être une force policière
s'il n'arrive pas à le faire nous irons
vers une guerre civile car je crains
qu'une partie des gens ne se laissera
pas lui ne se laisseront pas eu
islamisés en 12 dans le fond ils
prendront ils y aller ce risque là
naturellement d'avoir des affrontements
plus direct entre une partie de la
population qui palliera dans le fond des
manquements d'un état qui est un état
démissionnaire et donc je ne voudrais
pas arriver à cette éventualité là qui
me semblent plausibles et donc il faut
absolument que le gouvernement ou au
delà de vouloir sanctionner les réseaux
sociaux l'aude où l'ua de vouloir
sanctionner le ccf aille au coeur du
problème qui est le coeur du problème
c'est déjà d'aborder l'immigration
l'immigration de masse et déjà d'aborder
lille légalité que doit être la charia
au coeur de la france 7 7
cet enseignant a été à lui a vu sa tête
coupée ou non d une application de la
charia très très très très littéralement
qui invite naturellement à décapiter de
ce qui ce qui blasphème mais c'est
enseignant avait été coupable d'avoir
blasphémé puisqu'il avait montré les
dessins de mahomet à ses élèves
donc si on ne va pas au coeur du
problème si on n'est pas d'une brutalité
semblable à celle qui est exercée par
les islamistes qui ne connaissent que la
force
je crois que nous allons à notre perte
et ses paires peut être très rapide
vous le disiez l'un des sujets c'est
celui de l'immigration ou pas et il y à
débat
sur ce point il y a quelques jours le
président de la république présentait
les grandes lignes d'une loi contre les
séparatismes c'était avant le l'attentât
islamiste de vendredi dernier
l'immigration n'est pas au programme
le contrôle de l'immigration plus
précisément n'est pas au beau programme
de cette loi et je vous propose de voir
deux points de vue très très opposés sur
ce sujet d'abord celui de gérald
darmanin
il nous donnait une interview au figaro
magazine il ya une semaine dans lequel
il expliquait que non par nature les
étrangers ne commettent pas des actes
illégaux
ce n'est pas dans leur essence et je
peux vous dire que cette radio était
assez tendu parce que il vivait assez
mal cette cette accusation de mettre un
lien entre immigration et et islamisme
est encore plus terrorisme et il donnait
son sang son cas personnel et celui de
sa famille et puis voilà un autre point
de vue il est toujours dans le figaro de
ce matin celui d'alexis brézet le
directeur des rédactions qui lui pense
qu'il faudra se décider à aborder sans
se voiler la question de l'immigration
sans contrôle
et il ajoute si la france continue
d'accueillir chaque année sur son sol
près d'un million près d'un demi million
pardon d'étrangers dont la grande
majorité de confession musulmane qui
estime que la charia est supérieure à
tous il est peu probable que l'islamisme
recul laurent alexandre votre votre
point de vue faut-il juguler
l'immigration pour espérer un jour en
finir avec l'islamisme
une chose est certaine le masochisme
migratoire doit cesser la france n'a
aucune raison de continuer à faire venir
sur son territoire des gens qui la
déteste donc la première condition pour
arriver sur le sol français c'est
d'aimer la france d'aimer la
civilisation française et vouloir
s'intégrer
on fait rentrer des imams radicaux qui
haïssent la france toujours aujourd'hui
nous devons faire ce que font les
suisses pour rentrer en suisse il faut
vouloir s'intégrer mais la suisse est
respecté les valeurs suisses nous devons
faire la même chose
la france n'a aucune raison par un
masochisme incroyable de faire entrer
et à jet continu à jet continu des gens
qui la haïssent et qui vole sa mort donc
la france peut tout à fait faire venir
des immigrés y compris musulman et je ne
suis pas du tout islamophobe mais elle
doit exiger des migrants qu'ils aiment
la france je ne comprends pas pourquoi
on fait venir autant de gens qui
détestent la france mais vous pensez
bien que si on pose la question à des
gens qui veulent venir en france ils
répondront oui j'aime la france et ce
sera pas forcément simple et bien il
faut le prouver et il faut obtenir la
nationalité française
quand on l'a montré et pas simplement
par des astuces juridiques
la france doit prendre doit reprendre le
contrôle de sa politique migratoire
la france doit choisir qui devient
français et qui vit en france
la suisse n'est pas un régime néo nazis
mais vous ne devenez pas suisse si la
suisse n'a pas décidé que vous puisque
vous avez les qualités requises pour
être un citoyen suisse nous devons faire
ce que fait la suisse la suisse est un
pays très tranquille libérale non
dictatorial mais qui a développé une
immigration choisie
la france doit avoir une immigration
choisie il n'est pas honteux de décider
qui vient le samedi soir dîner chez vous
et prendre l'apéritif chez vous vous
choisissez vos copains est bien pour
l'immigration c'est la même chose
nous devons choisir les gens qui vont
rejoindre la communauté nationale
indépendamment du sexe de la race et de
la religion bien évidemment yvance un
point de vue coût défend d'être de
longue date pour vous il y a un lien
entre cette montée de l'islamisme et une
immigration importante dire qu'on vous
l'on peut on peut naturellement débat de
savoir si lien ou 10 un lien ou pas
entre l'immigration et la délinquance
mais il suffit de voir les faits il
suffit d'abord de voir la nationalité de
celui qui a tué ce professeur du souhait
de voir la prochaine wii et et d'autres
encore et donc je ne comprends pas
d'ailleurs la position de gérald
darmanin parce que je lui ai entendu
dire qu'il était à cent mille eu lieu je
me souviens de sa phrase à cent mille
lieues de ce qu'ils font un lien entre
l'immigration et la violence et
l'insécurité
donc si déjà à ce ministre de
l'intérieur qui pourtant se dit lucie de
garder les statistiques
et non il n'a pas regardé la réalité
pourtant qu'il se dit lucide et qui dans
ses premières déclarations dans le fond
le conviennent et silva à ce point dans
le conformisme de la pensée qui depuis
trente ans nous mène dans le mur je suis
très inquiet pour l'avenir et je pense
qu'en effet je suis d'accord avec vous
le lac est de souveraineté qui
aujourd'hui à nîmes tout le débat
politique passe naturellement par une
maîtrise ça va ce soir mais il faut il
faut le redire par une maîtrise de
l'immigration et le pour l'instant à
l'immigration n'est pas maîtrisée par la
france qui subit 450 mille entrées par
an en comptant ni comptant les éléments
de les mineurs isolés et donc c'est
naturellement aberrant parce que ce sont
des des flots de personnes qui viennent
gonfler naturellement des cités qui ne
s'intègrent aux publicités musulmane
pour la plupart d'entre elles qui ne
s'intègrent plus qui constituent des
ghettos et donc il faut revoir
totalement d'abord notre approche de
cette immigration qui est une approche
qui devient une approche très
problématique pour notre propre dignité
notre propre identité et il faut
remettre en question le droit du sol il
faut remettre en question la livre le
regroupement familial
il faut remettre en question tout c'est
tous ces principes qui sont des
principes sur qui aujourd'hui font font
notre faiblesse je pense que le droit du
sol qui donne la nationalité automatique
aujourd'hui à des jeunes nés de parents
étrangers mais qui sont nés en france
portent même une violence identitaire
auprès de ces jeunes là qui on le voit
dans les sondages se disent davantage
musulmans que français 74% des jeunes
musulmans se lisent davantage musulmans
que français donc leur faire porter une
disque email radar de leur religion au
dessus des lois de la république de sud
et louison ils ne se sentent donc pas
france et donc ils se sentent musulmans
vont se sentir français et donc ne
pouvait pas un plus leur imposer dans le
fond une mue une nationalité dans lequel
ils ne se reconnaissent pas une se
définit même quand vous leur dites
qu'ils sont ils se disent d'abord
musulmans avant d'être français je suis
navré donc il y as on peut poser ce
problème sans être traité de raciste et
je crois que il n'ya rien de plus beau
que d'avoir demandé n'ont pas le choix
de revenir son enfant au youth solistes
duos droit du sol qui avait été un temps
retenue par la révolution qui est de
dire que les français celui en effet
qu'il désire ardemment être français qui
se plie dans le fond aux règles qui se
soumet aux règles de la france aux
règles de la république et aux règles de
notre culture occidentale de ceux ci et
je pense qu'il faut pouvoir débattre
sans ce sens là
n'ont plus affronté les donneurs de sang
je vous donne les réactions de nos
internautes vous réagissez sur twitter
le hashtag point de vue mais aussi sur
youtube sur lefigaro.fr
christophe x nous dit la comparaison de
laurent alexandre avec la suisse est
très ambitieuse car c'est la nationalité
la plus compliquée à obtenir en europe
est ce que il n'ya pas une forme
d'injustice laurent alexandre à vouloir
fermer les frontières à tous les gens
qui qui veulent entrer en france et
peut-être qu'ils peuvent découvrir une
fois qu'ils sont chez nous que
les valeurs que nous avons en commun son
son
de nature à les leur permettre de
s'émanciper c'est dire que c'est un peu
un constat d'échec de diront on ferme
les frontières
enfin excusez moi mais l'immigration que
nous avons depuis 50 ans ne s'est pas
intégrer excusez moi ce jeune tchétchène
ne s'est pas intégrés aux valeurs de la
civilisation française
donc nous sommes en plein échec nous
devons y prendre acte nous laissons vous
notre politique migratoire est folle
elle faire entrer beaucoup trop de gens
qui haïssent la france et puis
globalement c'est pas politiquement
correct ce que je vais dire mais la
france exporte des cerveaux bac +5 et
importent beaucoup de cerveaux bac moins
5 très très peu qualifiés
cette situation est intenable elle
conduit à la ghettoïsation elle conduit
à la rancoeur la france doit revoir sa
politique migratoire
c'est peut-être ambitieux de faire comme
font les suisses mais les suisses n'ont
aucun problème migratoire et allez vous
promener à 2 heures du matin dans la
banlieue des villes suisses vous pouvez
y aller tranquillement alors que dans
les banlieues françaises
il n'est pas toujours très aisé de se
promener tout seul
à deux heures du matin donc le modèle
suisse d'immigration a prouvé sa force
et je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec votre auditeurs ce modèle il marche
remarquablement bien sur le plan
économique sur le plan politique sur le
plan sécuritaire sur le plan identitaire
les suisses n'ont pas tous les ennuis
que nous avons est d'ailleurs quand on
est en suisse les suisses ne comprennent
pas pourquoi on est maso comme je disais
tout à l'heure
et pourquoi on s'est créé autant
d'emmerdements pourquoi on a créé cette
situation folle dans lequel quand on
défend la liberté d'expression à l'école
on se fait égorger par un gamin dont les
parents ont eu la zil politique en
france l'état s'y étaient opposés c'est
le juge qui a imposé cette mesure donc
cette situation est folle en réalité en
matière migratoire et en matière
d'intégration la france est schizophrène
il faut qu'elle se réveille
sinon la sphère de conflans n'est que le
début de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
malheurs mais on est quand même
peut-être là un peu trop dans le tout ou
rien non ils vont rioufol parce que il
ya des des centaines de milliers
et de d'immigrants y compris de culture
musulmane qui se sont intégrés en france
que ça ne plaise qui se sentent
pleinement français et qui peut-être en
nous écoutant ce 10 mai mais c'est
injuste de raisonner comme ça de
globaliser d'essentialiser comme dirait
gérald darmanin et c'est une forme de
stigmatisation comme on dit aujourd'hui
oui mais je pense que là nous sommes
dans un tel état aujourd'hui de détresse
dans le fond de détresse sécuritaire de
détresse identitaire qu'il faut un
moratoire en tout cas moi je suis
d'accord avec vous peut-être peut-être
nous prend nous un mozart dans tous dans
tous ceux là qui veulent nous rejoindre
mais peut-être aussi éviteront nous
quelques terroristes qui voudront
également nous nous égorger mois le
principe de précaution que l'on applique
à l'excès du point de vue sanitaire me
semble être également essentiel
aujourd'hui du point de vue migratoire
donc j'entends bien à cet argument de
dire qu' il est injuste de rejeter tout
le monde aimait mais je trouve qu'il est
d'abord ahurissant par exemple pour
reprendre cette famille d'une jeune
tchétchène du duc du jeune tchétchène
que la france est vrai que la justice
française que la france n'avait avait
racheté et est admis ce tchétchène qui
lui prôné le jihad en russie donc il
faut quand même qu'il y ait un minimum
de vigilance également parce que ce site
va encore perdurer chez ceux que l'on
accueille qui viennent de pays
islamiques ou moins que lors que l'on
fasse en sorte que ces pays là soit mis
sur des listes rouges les à présent je
parle des pays islamiques par des pays
musulmans si je ne parle pas du maroc ni
l'algérie mais de tous les autres que ce
que cela soit déjà mis sur liste rouge
pour afin de d'éviter qu'il y ait à
nouveau d'autres risques supplémentaires
qui viendraient dans un djihad qui a
déclaré la guerre à tout le monde et qui
est temps d'en face de conquête
singulièrement dans son ventre mou qui
est la france
donc oui il est urgent de se réveiller
si l'on ne veut pas mourir merci
beaucoup merci à à tous les deux merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis point de vue
revient demain même heure même endroit
pour une nouvelle émission
bonsoir
[Musique]